what I think you're gonna see happen is
my sense is that as there are amendments
made modifications made to these
restrictions they're going to be
Geographic nature they're gonna happen
in regions and/or States
and they're not going to happen all at
once there's going to be a slow
progression to a point that we can
sustain because we're stories a balance
we're always gonna err on the side of
public health and public safety
there is also only so much you can ask
of a society before it begins to sort of
push back or not comply I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Reuben report joining me
today is the senior senator from Florida
Senator Marco Rubio welcome to the
Reuben report thanks Adam
well I'm glad you're doing this we've
been trying to get you for a long time
we were hoping we were maybe gonna do it
live in Florida
although the pandemic has at least
temporarily stopped us but let's just
get right to it because I know you have
limited time
well how's life in the middle of
lockdown what do you what are you going
through what are you hearing from people
in Florida the whole thing yeah it's a
tough time for a lot of people on
multiple levels obviously economically
at a time and tremendous uncertainty
it's disrupting people's daily routines
people stuck at home for weeks on end
and and so that's been a challenge then
obviously the health care part at this
point you know I can tell you we know at
least you know three people who have had
somebody in their family either died or
very seriously I hope this point from
the buyers so it's getting become
personal and then there's things you
don't really necessarily think about I
told you before we got on the air here
that have a senior in high schools my
daughter she that whole senior class
across the country that the rites of
passage the prom the graduation ceremony
all that's up in the air about what's
going to happen next so it's just
challenging on multiple fronts but but
obviously you're also think about these
people are going out every day whether
it's working at the grocery store and
exposing themselves to hundreds of
people daily or working in these
hospitals whether it's cleaning them or
all the way up to the doctors many of
them have been infected themselves it's
just a tremendous challenge that I know
this words been used a lot but it really
is nothing to compare it to yeah so I
want to spend most of our chat talking
about
the things that you're actually helping
pass to to help people but one quick
thing before we get to that what's your
general philosophy on what the states
should be doing right now versus what
the federal government should be doing
no I think it should be a state response
and the reason why is because states
every state is in a different situation
you know and I think they are number one
most accountable and there's to the
people directly and second I their
country in this big this diverse there's
very rarely you're gonna have a
one-size-fits-all approach that that
really functions well and so I think
that's why having the state response
it's not just the right thing to do on a
constitutional basis in my view it's
also common sense and what I think
you're going to see happen is my sense
is that as there are amendments made
modifications made to these restrictions
they're going to be Geographic in nature
they're gonna happen in regions and/or
states and they're not going to happen
all at once there's gonna be a slow
progression to a point that we can
sustain because we're so there is a
balance here we're always gonna err on
the side of public health and public
safety there is also so only so much you
can ask of a society before it begins to
sort of push back or not comply those
requirements so it's not like we have
unlimited time to continue to leave
these things in place forever at some
point there will have to be some
modifications because people will simply
stop complying and make it hard to
comply and and so it's a delicate
balancing act and that's why I think
it's important that it have a state a
basis for it do you guys have a
particularly unique situation in Florida
because weather-wise it's warm and
everyone's been saying hopefully as the
summer rolls around that that'll help
but on the other hand I assume Florida
probably has one of the older
populations oldest populations in the
United States well that's a good point
so for example we do have as far as you
know we have some none of our urban
areas are as densely populated as New
York City for example Sam in California
these are big cities but they're people
dry you can tell by how many people are
driving there do people use public
transportation tells you a lot about
density but the other thing that's you
mentioned is we do have not just a large
senior population but a large
concentrated senior population
everywhere from the villages in North
Central Florida to multiple facilities
studies and Southeast Florida and very
vibrant retiree communities in Southwest
Florida and so we have places where a
lot of people in that high-risk category
and over 65 or whatever live together
and so outbreaks in any of those places
could quickly you know strain the local
health services so that is one unique
aspect and the other is we have a lot of
international travel that comes through
here from all over the world and spread
from over the hemisphere so even if we
emerge from this at some point with good
numbers you know we're only an outbreak
in Latin America in the Western
Hemisphere away from seeing some of that
you know coming into our state commodity
whether it's visitors to Disneyworld or
people are coming to do business in
South Florida alright so I really want
to focus in on what the government is
actually hopefully doing right but maybe
some of what it's fumbling across the
way I know you've been heavily involved
in the paycheck protection program can
you talk a little bit about that yeah
the first thing I want to say about all
of it is understand the reason why I'm
not even involved is because the
government has told businesses they
can't function we can't open your doors
and can't make any money you can't work
so it is a government order it's an in
essence of taking in the public interest
is if I take your property way up to
compensate you for to the government if
I close your business there's got to be
some level of compensation for that so
what's the right way to do is we worked
on we focused on the small business
sector and the committee that I chair
and we came up with a formula because we
don't believe in I think I've been
proven right that the existing emergency
loan program was now functioned that
program is designed for a tornado or
flood or hurricane mitigated wildfire
that hits a geographic area not a
nationwide emergency so there's been a
lot of criticism about the glitches the
programs had and I just asked myself
what did people expect this bill passed
on March 27 for 17 days ago seven days
later the program was up and running
they're not perfectly 350 billion dollar
program half the businesses in America
are eligible for it's a massive program
and it's never been done before so on
that day almost two Fridays ago it was
the first time ever that anyone on this
planet had ever done a PPP long whether
you are banker the SBA or even somebody
applying to it so that was you know
seven days after the bill passed eleven
days after this program is started which
is where we are today we already have
billions of dollars being dispersed into
the accounts of small businesses there
are over a million small businesses that
have already been approved and are in
some process of getting this funding
representing millions of American jobs
that there's now a funding source to
keep them on payroll for six to eight
weeks I think that's a pretty
significant achievement over a very
short period of time yes they were
glitches of course there were glitches
that's the nature of crisis situations
but I don't know any precedent where you
have a program of this size and
magnitude that ramps up and begins to
reach people at such a massive level in
17 days from the day it was signed into
law yeah I'm not making this up we I
have a small business here obviously my
production company that backs this show
we found out about an hour ago that we
were actually cleared for one of the
small business loans so I know that you
know firsthand that this is actually
affecting people how do you decide
whether money should go to the small
businesses themselves or whether it
should just be put in people's pocket
for that sort of immediate burst if they
have to deal with mortgage and you know
buying groceries and medical supplies
things like that well the way we viewed
it was at least from our perspective was
two things it was good for most small
businesses to hold on to their employees
as long as they could because it would
be disruptive for them to have to lose
all their employees and try to rehire
everybody would add time and complexity
to starting up again depending on what
industry you're in they may never be
able to start up again yeah you can't
just hire someone off the street and
12-minutes train them how to use the dry
cleaning machine or even how to work the
systems for your restaurant so we also
think it's better for people to be
attached to an employer even if they're
not going into work and the evidence of
that is there are plenty of people out
there that are still getting paid but
either working from home in some cases I
am working at all but still paid I don't
see them you know asking to be laid off
for the most part and so the issue is we
wanted to keep that attachment at a time
of so much uncertainty the last thing
you want is people sitting at home not
just out of a job but not even knowing
that there's a job for them to go back
to any point in the near future so that
was the rationale behind it and the
question is what is the best way to
deliver it and the answer was not
through the SBA directly because this is
a small agency but no federally
secretive handled it we are rich every
small business has some banking
relationship of financial relationship
of some kind let's pay the bankers and
the lenders a processing clue to
basically do a no-risk loan on their
part because most of this is going to be
forgiven and whatever portion of it
becomes as long as it does is 100%
guaranteed by the federal government and
that was the general concept that
luckily began working weeks before we
were called upon because we kind of saw
this coming and that was the idea behind
it do you think this is all working
basically as well as it could be worked
as you said there's gonna be some clubs
there's gonna be some hiccups along the
way but do you think that the system
basically is functioning as it should
right now
yeah there's two impairments that people
have to understand the first is there
was some lateness and issuing the
guidance they opened up applications at
Friday their guidance think about so
Thursday because the original guidance
that was put out by SBA was did not
reflect legislative intent it was very
too complicated and so Treasury came and
they spent all day Thursday fixing it
finally came out on Friday then there
were some follow-up questions simple
things you know but important like what
note do we use what document do we use
to close the lung because we're not
going to close unless you tell us what's
approved because a year from now we
don't want you to come and tell us that
it's not guaranteed because we use the
wrong form
so getting Treasury to answer that
question is what really opened up the
door and then the third is and is there
a market to sell some of these because
if you hold these on your books that's
capital it's not cash that's going out
of cash out of the balances of these
lenders they want to make sure that at
some point in six seven eight weeks they
can sell these things to somebody so
when the Fed came out Friday and
announced that they would be able to
take them to the discount window and get
rid of these loans off to books and have
the feds own it that opened up the
spigot as well so I wish you would have
done all those things you know three
days earlier but there's a lot that goes
into that but it happened and then the
other issue is Frank pages capacity I
mean these are big banks but they didn't
have a thousand people assigned to
processing homes and to repurpose a lot
of their internal systems and employees
to handle this kind of work and train
them up on how to do it so some of the
backlog we've seen has been inside the
banks themselves we just weren't you
know internally this is not what they do
and so they had to repurpose a lot of
their existing folks to be able to do
some of this so I want to shift a little
bit and talk about China directly
because one of the reasons I've wanted
to have you on the show for so long is
I've heard you give many speeches on the
Senate floor about the uniqueness of
America and and why you love this
country so much and you know your family
story and the whole thing we seem to be
at this odd moment right now where we're
in this relationship with China that
nobody can quite tell if it's good if
it's bad if it's beneficial are we did
they spread it and now they're also
supposed to be our Savior can you clean
up a little bit about what's going on
with China and how we should be dealing
with them during this well look China is
a rich and powerful and important
country and will be for the rest of our
lifetime in fact this entire century
will be defined by the relationship
between the United States and China and
they for historic reasons and others
they view it is a rightful role in the
world from a historical perspective they
view the last hundred years of an
aberration and it's their rightful role
in the world to sort of be the most
dominant and powerful country on the
planet and every nation is entitled to
whatever ambitions they want but from
our perspective we have a relationship
with them and it has to be a balanced
relationship because the relationship
becomes unbalanced whether it's
geopolitically or economically we're
going to have a conflict we're already
seeing conflict within when it comes to
economics and what could eventually see
armed conflict as well which would be
disastrous and so the only way to avoid
that is to have a balanced relationship
work I I don't like the Chinese
Communist Party I wish they were more
democratic and they and they adhered
that human rights and I talked about
those things but ultimately that's
something that has to change over there
internally what we can control is where
our relationship in life with them and
we have made decisions and public policy
in this country for 25 years that have
disadvantage us because we thought that
when China got rich they would become
like us we didn't realize so recently I
guess most people is that what they were
actually undertaking is a very
meticulous carefully crafted and patient
effort to displace us and no longer to
be the place that makes cheap knockoffs
but the actual place that is innovating
and the concrete innovators that's fine
but
if their innovations are largely built
on intellectual property both an unfair
competition where their companies can be
whatever they want here but other
companies abroad can't do whatever they
want over there well that's not a fair
playing field and so we need to bring
some balance to that relationship and
that's not what exists right now and so
I think we have to spend a lot of time
working on I'm restoring a level of
strategic balance both economical is
your holding so speaking of strategic
balance I mean the fact that we're
getting so many of our supplies from
China the fact that our supply chain has
so much to do with China I mean in a
certain way has the ship sailed on that
like how do we actually fix some of this
stuff especially because we're going
through this right now it's not like all
right maybe six months from now we can
do the post-mortem on it and figure out
here the mistakes we made but we
actually do need things right now
yeah United States but this is we we've
given it away because we made a decision
and the market said that the most
efficient place for these activities to
happen is somewhere else and China
became that place and it became the most
efficient place initially because of low
labor costs but now it's also because
they subsidize and protective companies
at the expense of everybody else and
generally that's fine that's the way
capitalism should work that's why I
support markets but what happens when
the most efficient outcome is opposite
of our national interest so for example
what happens when the most efficient
outcome is that airplanes are only made
in China and rare earth minerals can
only be procured from China and key
medications can only come from China
well I'm not sure that's in our national
interest and some of that is being
exposed right now you know I'll tell you
something that we can do here that it's
very difficult to offshore is
agriculture and so you have some
commodities and some disruptions the one
thing you're not hearing about is there
may not be any toilet paper at the
grocery store but there's meat there's
chicken and there's rice and there's
vegetables that issue is not hurting us
because we can feed ourselves we and and
and we can found an industry we can just
pick up and move somewhere else we're
very fortunate we need to be able to do
some other things that may not be the
most efficient place to do but we have
to have some capability of doing certain
things
and we I think one of the key pieces of
work that we have to put together in the
aftermath of all this is defining what
are those industries that we're going to
have to have some domestic capacity and
for purposes of national economic and
national security so as we look at you
know the stimulus package and we look at
you know refiguring out our situation
with China and everything else what does
getting America back to work look like I
mean I know you're saying the states
should all sort of do their own thing
but like are we is this now the rest of
the year do you think is this well
beyond that I mean what does this
actually kind of look like if you
artists question you know certain anyone
who goes around talking to dates is
lying
they just no one really knows yet but I
think it really begins a sort of setting
in our mind a criteria for what is an
acceptable level of risk and and
remembering that we don't have an
unlimited amount of time here we're
asking people to comply with these
orders but eventually people will begin
to push back on compliance they're just
stopped complying and we're not going to
be arresting everyone who decides
they're going to break a curfew or
because 10 people are together at home
somewhere so this is not forever we
cannot do this even if we wanted to
forever and we don't want to and we
can't from an economic perspective the
second is what have we done in the
interim what are we doing right now are
we developing we can develop an
antiviral that keeps people off
respirators keeps people out of ICU
maybe even keeps them out of the
hospital that's a major development and
we're much closer to that than we are to
a vaccine which will eventually come and
then I think part of it for all of us is
recognizing that it's not going to be
like we're gonna go back to March first
and everything's gonna open up and be
the same I think it's going to be a
gradual process of adjustment and I
still expect that for some significant
period of time many of us will still be
wearing masks in public places we'll
still have to stand six feet apart in
the lines and we may not be able to
gather in large groups at certain places
and you know what that can mean I mean
all kinds of things that would be
disrupted by it so things may reopen
some jobs may come back but it won't be
the same for a while and that's going to
have economic consequences to it as well
and so it reminds me a lot of the
Hurricanes that we've become accustomed
to here in Florida we're sitting at home
you know it's a bad storm on the radio
you can hear the wind howl and see the
trees
maybe I'm breaking you don't really know
how bad it is until the storm passes and
go outside and take an assessment and
then we're still in the middle of that
storm and and this storms going to
linger a little bit even after we go
outside it's still going to be blowing
there's gonna be a tail to some of the
second out of damage Wow yeah I want to
ask you something that I talked to a lot
of my non-political guests about but it
might be interesting to hear our
politicians view on this have you been
able to have any time to sort of just
rethink what you're doing with your life
what do you want to do in the future
what you're doing with your family just
you know everyone trapped at home I I do
sense the the silver lining to all of
this is that we are gonna start thinking
about the world in a new way what job we
have whether we want to commute where
we're living are we too close to a big
city etc etc have you guys had any time
to talk about that either with your wife
with your kids what they want to do all
that sort of thing
a little different I think and for me
it's been more about what our humbling
is fairness is for everybody this is not
a disease that wealth fame power
protects you from and the Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom and gravely ill
we've seen celebrities and very wealthy
people do infected by it so this is
something that that sort of reminds you
that there are things we still don't
control we are in advanced species we've
done some extraordinary things in the
last hundred years scientifically and
yet there are things we cannot control
there are things that that we are we are
still limited I think to as much as
anything else and this is a reminder of
how all of these things we've built all
of even you see these massive companies
and captains of industry that were
brought to their knees very quickly
because the economy came to a halt by a
virus by a bot by biology and and so it
sort of reminds you that in so many ways
while we have great advances and have
achieved tremendous things as a species
we still have limits to the things that
we have control over and that there are
some things that are not easy to solve
we've also become a society that's used
to why haven't you invented the pill yet
that takes this away in five minutes
great why didn't you come up with a
magic government program that makes us
all go away overnight and it's almost
this assumption that somehow there's
this logical easy solution out there we
just haven't done it because people
don't want to do it every country in the
world is struggling with this because
there are certain things in life still
in the 21st century
that require a lot of work a little bit
of patience a little bit of humility in
confronting them because they don't have
easy answers and don't have easy
solutions and and for me that certainly
reminded us that no matter how powerful
the US government might be and how much
influence we may have in in from our
role there's only so much we can we can
do but our job is to do our best
yeah all right so one more then which is
sort of jumps off that and sort of
related to some of the speeches that
I've heard you you give is there
something that is unique about the
American experience about just American
Drive and ingenuity and the desire and
an action on freedom that you think will
will help us get through this where
other countries might struggle in a way
because it's not so much in their
national ethos where we have such a
strong just independent streak within us
yeah to the first students our sense of
community where you see people out there
right now at home sewing masks and doing
certain things that to help out in their
own way you've seen entire businesses
that repurpose their production for
purposes of throwing they heard about a
critical need in society and they
decided we were going to meet it you see
so many people step up to the plate on
there even in this time there's so much
polarization a lot of that happen and
some of the most amazing stories have
nothing to do with famous people or
political people it has to do with
everyday people that are making
extraordinary steps to check on a
neighbor or provide food for some an
elderly person was shattered at home and
can't go outside because their life
would be at risk so I think that and
some of the stories you hear a news
emergency these patients are completely
isolated from loved ones and you know
doctors are holding up the phone before
they intubate them so they could speak
to the relatives potentially for the
last time and the impact its had on them
psychologically so just extraordinary
stuff and then the second part about it
is our creativity and innovation you
have a lot of creative innovative people
out there right now that are trying to
solve all sorts of problems you know the
fact that you and I are having this
interview despite the inability to be
together and then 20 years ago I don't
need a studio now we're doing it you
know on two laptops or two computers and
so that for the record I as a small
business man I do have a home studio
this is my garage not bad right
this is not but the thing is that that
you we have we have that creativity not
just to solve the problems with facing I
mean kids are learning yeah it's not
ideal in the classroom with friends but
there we're we're instructing people all
these are innovations will America
brought about in many ways are made it
possible but the other thing that's
happening is they're working on
solutions to this problem I'm I I
believe the brightest minds in the world
the bride's minds in this country
thinking about parking leaking with a
vaccine how can we come up with an
antiviral how can we make ventilators
and you're already seen some of these
companies turn it around and take small
things and repurpose it if it to be
between waiters and medical protective
gear and so forth so that extraordinary
power is still there when our minds are
behind a United purpose and you see that
it's evident people aren't just sitting
at home saying when is the government
gonna come up with an answer the media
might be asking that but but every day
people run out and answering the
question themselves in their own
communities that's a very unique
American attribute the one that I'm glad
we still have I love that answer and
Senator I thank you for taking the time
and stay safe
and hopefully we'll be able to do this
in person sometime absolutely thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell